en este vídeo vamos a hablar de la
actualización del cableado para la
cámara quitamos los cables del botón de
encendido de la cámara de donde los
teníamos en nuestra configuración de
transistor y resistencia
los torcemos juntos y vamos a usar un
trenzado de cables que es esta etapa
naranja aunque no nos sirve porque es
muy grande así que mejor los soldados
usando cautín y soldadura y así podremos
tomar fotos en un instante ya que
teníamos problemas porque el encender la
cámara hacía que se tardará mucho tiempo
en tomar una foto
ahora vamos a conectar manualmente
nuestro disparador y vemos que toma las
fotos casi instantáneamente ya que ahora
la cámara está encendida todo el tiempo
ahora quitamos la resistencia y el
transistor de nuestro botón de encendido
y re conectamos los cables del botón de
disparo de manera que disminuye el
tiempo que le toma tomar fotos esto
podría vaciar más pronto nuestras
baterías
está bien para lo que necesitamos
cortamos un poco de nuestro tubo de
plástico que se encoge y usamos la
pistola de aire caliente para que se
encoja y proteja nuestra conexión vamos
a poner esto dentro de la estructura de
bits y bot y no nos preocuparemos mucho
por esto ya que vimos que funciona y
mejora notablemente el tiempo en que
toma las fotos lo que es importante
ponemos cinta en este extremo para
asegurar nuestra nueva conexión y lo
colocamos dentro de nuestra estructura
como habíamos dicho ahora si nuestra
cámara responde con mayor rapidez que
antes aquí nos dimos cuenta de que no
podemos descargar las fotos de la cámara
porque su puerto queda por debajo del
borde de nuestra estructura así que
necesitamos modificar la estructura
externa para poder acceder al puerto de
la cámara vamos a cortar un poco de la
estructura para poder conectar el cable
a la cámara más fácilmente
nos dimos cuenta de esto porque apenas
se nos ocurrió descargar las fotos de
prueba cortamos un poco el material para
poder elevar el lado derecho de la
cámara ya quitamos este pedacito y ahora
quitamos las tuercas para poder elevar
un poco la cámara
ajustamos las tuercas que están por
debajo de la tarjeta para elevarla lo
suficiente como para que podamos
conectar el puerto usb de la cámara
nos ayudamos con el destornillador para
ajustar las tuercas de abajo de la
tarjeta y verificamos que podemos
conectar el cable de micro usb a la
cámara si se puede está bien y ahora
ponemos de nuevo las tuercas que van por
encima de la cámara para asegurarla en
su lugar